bienvenidos de vuelta en este vídeo
vamos a seguir retomando la idea de
integral definida para esto voy a
continuar con lo que vimos en el vídeo
pasado en el cual tomamos a la distancia
como una función del tiempo la distancia
era igual a 16 t cuadrado y al graficar
lo que nos salía una media parábola que
empezaba en el origen y solamente tenía
sentido para tiempos positivos ya con
esta función de distancia lo que nos
preguntamos es cómo podíamos obtener la
velocidad y nos dimos cuenta que la
velocidad instantánea se obtenía al
derivar esta función es decir la
derivada de s con respecto al tiempo es
igual a 32 t que al graficar no nos sale
una recta muy empinada y fue aquí cuando
nos hicimos la pregunta más importante
del vídeo pasado si nosotros tenemos
solamente esta ecuación nosotros
solamente sabemos la ecuación de la
velocidad como podemos obtener la
ecuación de la distancia por ejemplo
supongamos que queremos saber la
distancia que hemos recorrido cuando en
el tiempo han pasado 10 segundos si
solamente tenemos la ecuación de la
velocidad para resolver esta pregunta la
relación que no sabemos nada acerca de
la función de la distancia no sabemos su
gráfica ni siquiera
que la derivada de la distancia es la
velocidad o dicho otra manera la anti
derivada de la velocidad es la distancia
y sin saber nada de esto la idea para
resolver esta pregunta fue tomar unos
intervalos de tiempo muy pequeños tan
pequeños con una millonésima de segundo
o más pequeños lo que ustedes quieran
casi instantáneos pero esos intervalos
nos van a ayudar a resolver el problema
la idea de tomar tiempos pequeños es muy
importante porque si tenemos tiempos muy
cercanos entonces su velocidad va a ser
muy cercana dicho de otra manera en un
tiempo casi instantáneo la velocidad es
constante y ahora sí ya que tenemos este
pequeño intervalo de tiempo lo que
construye fue una pequeña columna o un
pequeño rectángulo con una altura de la
velocidad que era constante y después
recordando que yo tengo la fórmula
clásica de velocidad que es igual a la
distancia entre tiempo y despejando de
aquí a la distancia es decir distancia
es igual a velocidad por tiempo yo tengo
que esta área que voy a colorear aquí de
morado base es mi distancia en este
pequeño intervalo de tiempo es decir ya
estoy resolviendo mi pregunta para un
intervalo de tiempo casi instantáneo
ahora bien si extiendo esta idea a todo
un intervalo de 0 a 10 segundos y lo
parto en pequeños intervalos y a cada
uno de los intervalos hago el mismo
procedimiento entonces puedo obtener una
buena y primera aproximación acerca de
la distancia total que yo he recorrido
hasta mis primeros 10 segundos y bien
hasta que nos quedamos en el vídeo
anterior ahora lo que quiero que
analicemos es que si nosotros tenemos
cada vez más rectángulos es decir si
nosotros hacemos la partición del tiempo
cada vez más pequeña mi aproximación va
a ser mucho mejor es decir nosotros cada
vez que tengamos más rectángulos vamos a
concluir dos cosas muy importantes la
primera es que la anti derivada va a ser
igual al área bajo la curva y la segunda
es que entre más rectángulos tengamos
vamos a ir obteniendo una mejor
aproximación hasta llegar al valor real
de la distancia que hemos recorrido
cuando han pasado 10 segundos de tiempo
de hecho pueden ser 10 segundos de
tiempo o el tiempo que ustedes quieran
el tiempo es una variable no importa y
aunque no sea que tan familiarizado
estés con la idea de sumatoria y de
hecho yo cuando vi por primera vez
sumatoria en cálculo uno no estaban nada
familiarizado lo que sí quiero decir
es que la integral definida es una suma
de rectángulos fíjense la integral de
hecho se parece a una sigma la integral
definida va a ser la suma de todos estos
rectángulos que he hecho de dónde a
dónde a pues empecé en un tiempo igual a
cero entonces lo voy a poner en la parte
de abajo en la parte de abajo de mi
integral es donde empieza una integral
en el tiempo igual a cero hasta el
tiempo igual a 10 en este caso en este
caso particular uno puede tomar
cualquier caso que uno quiera aprender
entonces queremos la integral definida
desde el tiempo igual a cero hasta el
tiempo igual a 10 que pongo en la parte
de arriba de la integral del área de
cada uno de mis rectángulos pero el área
es base por altura es decir la altura
que es ver a la velocidad y la velocidad
vale 32 t entonces le voy a poner 32 cm
por la base pero la base era dt era ese
pequeño intervalo de tiempo entonces voy
a hacer la integral de 32 t de t y ya
está con esto por fin tengo la integral
definida desde el tiempo igual a 0 hasta
el tiempo igual a 10 de la función 32
tdt
y con esto ya estoy sacando mi anti
derivada y que era lo mismo un área bajo
la curva o dicho de otra manera ya
cuando esto voy a obtener la distancia
total que he recorrido desde el tiempo
igual a cero hasta el tiempo igual a 10
segundos bueno que resuelva una
imprudencia y antes de proseguir a
resolver esta integral yo si quisiera
hacer una observación estoy tomando un
bonche de rectángulos discretos es decir
estoy tomando una cantidad de
rectángulos finita ya cada uno de estos
pequeños rectángulos yo lo que voy a
hacer es sumarle sus áreas para así
obtener la integral definida de hecho
una computadora cuando quiere calcular
una integral definida lo que hace es
precisamente eso hacer una partición
discreta de ese intervalo y calcular
cada uno de sus rectángulos sin embargo
la definición formal de la integral
definida no es la suma de una cantidad
finita de rectángulos la integral
definida es la suma de una cantidad
infinita de rectángulos de hecho yo lo
que voy a querer es que el ancho de los
rectángulos osea dt hacerle atender a
cero para que se obtenga una infinidad
de rectángulos y así la integral
definida va a ser una suma infinita
de cada uno de los rectángulos pero
bueno eso lo vería en uno de los
siguientes vídeos por ahorita solamente
quiero obtener el área bajo la curva
porque el área debajo de la curva que
estoy buscando es la distancia que he
recorrido hasta el tiempo de 10 segundos
pero bueno recapitulemos un poco
entonces estamos diciendo que esta
integral definida lo que me está
diciendo son dos cosas que el anti
derivada es el área bajo la curva y
además que la distancia recorrida hasta
el tiempo de 10 segundos va a ser la
solución de esta integral así que pues
vamos a resolverla para esto voy a
necesitar borrar un poco para tener algo
de espacio entonces vamos a borrar que
será bueno porque aquí creo que todo me
sirve creo que podemos prescindir de de
esta información
entonces voy a borrar todo esto bien
bien y ya está ok aquí voy a acabar está
integrado y como se dan cuenta mis
presentaciones no siempre estaban tan
bien planeadas tengo que borrar algunos
espacios pero espero que nada os moleste
ya casi acabamos está integrado entonces
solamente falta resolver esta integral
que yo tengo aquí y es una interfaz
sencilla de resolver es una de las
integrales que ya sabemos
lo único diferente es que tenemos que
evaluar entonces lo voy a poner aquí la
integral
me gusta el símbolo de la integral se
parece mucho a sigma la integral de
donde de 0 a 10
es una integral definida de 0 a 10 de
quien de 32 t diferencial de t muy bien
ahora el paso que sigue es resolver esta
integrales implicarnos en los límites de
integración como si fuera una integral
no definida indefinida ok entonces lo
que voy a hacer es la integral de 32
teques 16 de cuadrada porque pues porque
la integral de este cuadrado entre 2 por
32 me da 16 y esto evaluado de 0 a 10
ojo en las integrales definidas no se
ponen la constante y ahora sí voy a
evaluar 16% porque es dice al cuadrado y
16 x 0 que es cero y 16% es 1600 pies
que he caminado hasta el segundo 10 de
mi recorrido ya tengo por fin la
distancia que yo quería obtener y además
ya tengo el área bajo la curva serían
1.600 unidades de
bajo la curva bueno espero que haya
quedado muy claro este ejercicio así que
vamos a intentar hacer otro ejercicio
con las mismas ideas y con la misma
noción solamente que un poco más difícil
y un poco más directo entonces voy a
borrar toda la pantalla bien y ok y
ahora voy a tener otra vez está esta
línea está horrible perdón perdón
voy a tener voy a agarrar la la
herramienta de las líneas voy a tener
otra vez dos gráficas una gráfica que va
a comparar la distancia con el tiempo a
través muy parecido el problema pasado y
ahora voy a hacer otra gráfica donde voy
a tener la velocidad a comparación
también del tiempo entonces ya lo tengo
aquí
bien
y voy a decir que esta es la primera
gráfica es la gráfica de la distancia
contra el tiempo pero no voy a empezar
esta vez en el origen voy a empezar en
un punto un poco más arriba del origen
es decir ya voy a tener una distancia
inicial en mi distancia y decía él va a
ser desde aquí supongamos que va a ser a
5 pies entonces voy a poner aquí un 5
para acordarnos de que son 5 pies donde
yo inicié bien y entonces aquí crece mi
función que tiene que ver con la
distancia que es una función del tiempo
este es el tiempo y está este eje va a
ser el eje de la distancia entonces le
voy a poner ese de distancia bien y ya
se me está acabando el tiempo entonces
para no hacer este vídeo mucho más largo
le vamos a seguir en el siguiente vídeo
no se lo pierdan